une production du studio SF
iltre le
podcasts
avec moi dôme plante
cette semaine juste nous deux date on
fait un qni on a fait plusieurs à plus
facile on aime ça nous permet d'aller
s'exprimer exprimer notre créativité
puis me permettre de se parler en nous
aussi se passer dans le fond c'est comme
notre aussi notre ketchup notre ketchup
c'est le moment où est-ce qu'on ne faut
des fois
on s'ouvre plus qu'on s'ouvrirait dans
la vie vaut la peine vous laisserez à la
maison
enfin qu'on a pris vos questions sur
Instagram et on y répondra pleine
question des plus soit personnels notre
relation à nous soit sur la société
l'environnement
tout ce que vous voudrez
en début de podcast je partage une
nouvelle information
pour moi en tout cas
écoutez vraiment pas ça manquez pas ça
puis quelque chose qu'on dit à fin du
podcast aussi que je veux réitérer ici
si vous avez des questions pour un
prochain qui connaît par contre on va en
refaire on aime vraiment le format
posez-les que ce soit dans les
commentaires sur Youtube ou si vous
écoutez en audio seulement allez nous
écrire sur Instagram sans filtre podcast
puis on va prendre les questions pour
les prochaines fois fait que sans plus
attendre bon podcast bon écoute le
podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
infobref info bref c'est quoi on vous en
avez déjà parlé puis ça fait partie de
ma vie au quotidien il faut bref c'est
des bulletins de nouvelles qui résument
l'actualité en quelques qui se lit en
quelques minutes ou ce qui s’écoute en
quelques minutes maintenant moi je suis
abonné à l'infolettre puis à chaque
matin je me réveille pigé dans ma dans
ma boîte aux lettres un message de info
bref qui m'explique toutes les grandes
lignes de l'actualité donc je vais juste
lire ça me prend honnêtement 3 minutes à
lire puis je suis au courant de ce qui
se passe dans l'actualité puis
maintenant ils ont lancé une nouvelle
affaire maintenant c'est infobref il y a
maintenant le info bref balado qui va
vous résumer l'essentiel de l'actualité
dans un balado de 3 minutes en fait elle
a deux à chaque jour le actualité
infoprix qui vous résume l'essentiel des
nouvelles
internationales et nationale pour être
au courant de tout ce qui se passe sans
passer trop de temps vous écoutez ça en
faisant votre café le matin et on a un
essentiel on suit l'actualité sans avoir
le sans avoir besoin de lire tous les
journaux et il y a également le info
bref à faire qui résume les nouvelles
dans le monde de des affaires de mon
technologie totalement de l'innovation
espère intéressant au final même contenu
que le format
infolettre il faut l'être mais sous
forme de balado ouais puis nous
évidemment étant donné qu'on fait une
collaboration l'essayer et puis même la
première fois qu'on avait fait la tester
pour info bref on s'était abonnés à
l'infolette puis moi comme je vous dis
j'ai pas changé mon abonnement parce que
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je
consomme à tous les jours si vous voulez
suivre l'actualité mais vous avez pas de
nécessairement le temps assez des fois à
faire une revue de presse c'est vraiment
long puis des fois on veut juste avoir
le qu'est-ce qui se passe rester à
l'affût des dernières nouvelles ben
c'est parfait pour vous pouvez aller au
info bref.com
infof.com puis on va mettre un lien dans
la description du podcast qui en fait
utiliser ce lien là parce que ça va leur
indiquer que ça provient du sans fil
podcast donc vous encourager sans filtre
en vous éduquant en restant à l'affût de
l'actualité puis un encourageant il faut
bref de continuer à faire des nouvelles
sans publicité complètement gratuit
c'est idéal tu le baise merci il faut
bref
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par nos amis chez manscape qui viennent
de sortir le kit
ultime pour la barbe ici c'est le build
Edge qui est un trimard pour la barbe
puis la chose ultime dans ce produit là
c'est que vous pouvez décider il y a
quand même une petite roulette autour
qui décide la longueur que vous voulez
avoir de votre barbe ça va de 0.5
jusqu'à 10 puis moi c'est un problème
que j'avais parce que on en parlait
souvent je me faisais la barre avec le
voyons le
lendemain 4.0 mais lendemain il y avait
deux longueurs seulement
ceux-là il y a toutes les longueurs que
vous voulez dans le fond c'est clair à
partir de maintenant je vais pouvoir
avoir la barbe idéale tout le temps
c'était pas un million de petites pièces
que le nom par terre idéale
ce n'est que la longueur idéale puis en
plus de ça en plus de dans le paquet du
build ager ça vient avec plein d'autres
affaires d'hommes Parlement
là-dedans tu as vraiment tout ce que tu
as besoin pour avoir la barbe
même la barbe
toujours de mal one bear gourdement puis
dans le fond on a même une petite marche
à suivre qui est détaillée ici on a tout
ce que on a besoin pour laver la barbe
on a un shampoing à barbe après ça on va
se peigner avec ce petit peigne là après
ça on va se
tendre cette trimer la barbe à la
longueur idéale avec ceux on se fait une
petite finition au ciseau après ça on la
brosse et on se mette pas mal une petite
huile qu'elle soit bien
bien lisse et bien placé et parfaite
donc avec une barbe comme ça ça va
changer votre vie c'est sûr si vous ou
quelqu'un dans votre vie a une barbe
c'est un Game changer honnêtement là
nous on a reçu les trucs là je ramène ça
chez nous définitivement puis ça va être
ma nouvelle routine de barbe puis on a
un code promo pour vous autres qui est
le même code qu'on utilise tout le temps
c'est le sans fil pour 20% de rabais et
la livraison gratuite sur tous les
produits manscape mais principalement le
nouveau build ager donc sauter là dessus
puis oubliez pas de l'huile que le promo
comme ça ils vont savoir que c'est nous
qui vous envoie c'est bon pour tout le
monde c'est bon pour vous qui avez une
barbe c'est bon pour la personne que
vous connaissez Gavin barbe c'est bon
pour nous c'est bon pour mannequin c'est
bon pour Nicole qui nous écoute en ce
moment c'est bon pour tout le monde ok
promo sans fil 20% de rabais livraison
gratuite sur télé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est parti oh yeah
puis je vous aurez la réponse est bonne
les gens ils me sautent
je t'ai écrit la semaine passée je pense
ouais parce que j'ai puis là je vais en
parler sur le Podcast parce que je pense
vraiment que c'est d'intérêt général ok
c'est là on vient de tourner le podcast
avec Hugo meunier sur la sur l'alcool
qui est l'intérêt public puis dans le
podcast je suis content d'apprendre que
tu connais le youberman Lab je l'ai
connu Hélène aujourd'hui
[Musique]
au contraire de Morgan au grand
contraire de je regarde c'est un podcast
qui est basé sur des études pear reviews
fait que c'est des études crédibles des
méta-analyses puis des choses comme ça
vraiment scientifiques puis le podcast
c'est le concept de base du podcast le
gars c'est enjoy youberman qui est un
professeur à Stanford son podcast n'est
pas lié à son travail de professeur il
mentionne souvent sauf qu'il y a un LAPT
de recherche en neurosciences puis son
champ d'intérêt principal c'est la santé
mentale et physique dans un point de vue
de longévité et de performance donc
c'est sûr qu'il l'intéresse peu importe
c'est quoi que ce soit la consommation
de l'alcool quand on part dans le
podcast avec Hugo au sujet de l'impact
que ça peut avoir sur le long terme ou
bien carrément
quel type d'entraînement est le mieux
pour l'hypertrophie musculaire ou quel
type d'entraînement permet de vieillir
le plus long le plus lentement toutes
ces choses là toujours avec la science
basé toujours toujours basé sur la
science je l'ai écouté puis justement
j'ai tout le temps le sceptique en moi
se dit est-ce que ce gars ou c'est un
autre podcast de santé en guillemets que
finalement il pousse des produits de
poser des affaires puis ils disent un
peu n'importe quoi puis j'ai checké
c'est ça
peut-être des experts
dans la science il dit c'est pas clair
dans la science c'est ça
il est capable de dire ça d'exprimer ça
c'est ça bref là je vais faire une
parenthèse qui est tu vas voir parce que
je vais en venir moi ça fait à peu près
6 ans que j'ai arrêté de faire de la
compétition de natation à un haut niveau
est-ce que c'était comme un peu le
centre de ma vie puis que tout était mis
dans la direction d'être capable d'être
le meilleur deux fois par jour quand
j'avais m'entraîner toi
ça valait pas grand chose mais depuis
j'ai arrêté de manger
les après-midi
c'est toujours top toujours top j'arrive
à deux heures trois heures puis là j'ai
un coup de barre je fais comme je suis
fatigué fait que le soit je fais une
sieste
quand j'ai le temps quand chez nous puis
je me sens mal de faire une sieste alors
que c'est des heures ouvrables mettons
que
monsieur madame tout le monde qui vit sa
vie à Paul la chance de faire une sieste
alors que moi je travaille la maison et
puis je peux gérer mon arrêt un peu
comme je veux une sieste ou soit
inconsciemment ce que je me suis mis à
faire c'est de planifier ma journée en
conséquence mettons je me laver le matin
je fais des tâches qui me demande un
effort cognitif en matinée je vais
m'entraîner en fin d'avant midi j'arrive
l'après-midi puis là je me garde des
tâches qui me demandent moins de
concentration ou des choses plus
mécaniques mettons pour être capable de
pallier à ce genre puis là moi je me
disais
c'est comme ça que le monde se sent le
monde qui qui font pas de sport comme
j'en faisais genre
je viens ici je me disais j'ai 30 ans
mon grand-père qui fait des siestes
depuis 20 ans je me dis ben écoute même
c'est peut-être ça maintenant c'est
peut-être là je suis rendu genre je suis
fatigué l'après-midi et puis ça va être
ça va être moins productif puis là
j'essaie de rationaliser pourquoi je me
sentais même l'après-midi puis je sais
que ça va peut-être te rejoindre parce
que je sais que toi aussi des fois
l'après-midi tu veux faire des siestes
tout de suite c'est un sieste quand même
mais ça fait vraiment moins de 6
maintenant presque plus puis finalement
puis en plus c'est que je dormais bien
puis oui je m'entraînais beaucoup mais
je peux pas croire que c'est ça qui fait
que l'après-midi j'arrive chez nous je
suis brûlée s'il y en a qui nous
écoutent qui trouve pas ça intéressant
un peu skipper mais je suis sûr que ça
rejoint quand même pas mal de monde
puisque cette guesser qu'est-ce que tu
vas me dire tu peux essayer ce que tu
veux est-ce que tu fais des non est-ce
que tu fais le jeune intermittent non ok
continue
fait avant les icebad j'ai pas les
installations mais à la lumière de la
science de ce qu'on en dit c'est amené
d'une maison j'aurais peut-être me
mettre en iceberg en arrière parce que
ça a l'air d'avoir des bénéfices réels
mais c'est pas du tout ça
puis
c'est quand j'ai écouté l'épisode de
youberman Lab sur la caféine OK puis moi
j'arrivais dans cet épisode là en me
disant il va sûrement me dire même de
pas prendre la caféine pour plein de
raisons que on pense peut-être le titre
puis je me disais j'ai pas envie de
l'écouter mais en même temps je consomme
quand même beaucoup de café fait je vois
l'écouter
fait que là je l'écoute puis le podcast
commence en disant la caféine c'est un
outil extrêmement puissant pour les
capacités physiques pour
les capacités cognitives c'est vraiment
efficace que ce soit pour le temps de
réaction ta capacité à aller chercher
dans ta banque d'informations pour avoir
une réponse plus rapide que ce soit de
rester concentré plus longtemps que ce
soit d'être plus explosif dans un effort
que ce soit de réduire la fatigue dans
un effort musculaire de longue durée ça
va vraiment beaucoup de bénéfices
la caféine ce que c'est essentiellement
c'est pas un élément stimulant c'est
quelque chose qui vient bloquer tes
récepteurs de fatigue puis il parle la
fatigue et quantifiable tu peux mesurer
la fatigue dans le corps de quelqu'un
c'est une molécule x puis la caféine
vient couper les récepteurs de cette
moléculeurs ton cerveau fait ça envoie
pas le signal à ton corps ton cerveau
reçoit pas le signal de ton corps qui
est fatigué
il dit que plusieurs façons de d'évacuer
ces molécules de fatigue là le sommeil
en étant vraiment une une importante
sauf que ce qui mentionne c'est là la
hache de guerre du truc ce qui mentionne
c'est que biologiquement quand on se
réveille il y a deux heures après notre
réveil que le corps continue à évacuer
des molécules de fatigue pratiquement à
la même fréquence que quand on dort
6h puis la majorité des gens dorment en
6 et 8 heures donc
c'est un tiers de ta nuit que tu peux
prolonger puisqu'il explique c'est que
l'être humain est fait pour que le matin
en se réveillant on sorte à l'extérieur
on bouge on voit le soleil puis que
bouger et voir le soleil c'est des
choses qui permettent d'accentuer encore
plus la capacité de ton corps évacuer la
fatigue dans les deux heures avant de te
réveiller si quand tu te réveilles
première chose que tu fais tu bois un
café tu es bloquer les récepteurs de
fatigue dans ton cerveau ton cerveau
pense plus que de fatigue fait qu'il
arrête de l'évacuer
faites-le lui ce qu'il dit c'est pas la
caféine le problème le problème c'est
quand les gens en consomment dit 90 à
120 minutes après ton levait tu prends
pas de caféine
tu vas dehors tu t'exposes au soleil tu
bouges puis lui il dit que le soleil ça
peut être remplacé par une lampe là pour
des gens qui sont au Québec comme nous
est-ce que quand tu travailles pas le
soleil muramur
puis après ça tu prends ton café faites
là moi j'écoute ça sur ma longue robe le
samedi puis ça fait à peu près un mois
que je fais ça ma langue le samedi le
dimanche je fais ma routine normale le
lundi je me dis je vais commencer j'ai
compris la perte parce que après ça
excuse-moi j'ai manqué un bout important
il dit quand après ça ton café du matin
quand tu viens le prendre entre le vent
quand les fêtes ton café s'en va début
d'après-midi tu as la fatigue accumulée
que t'as pas réussi à évacuer de la
veille plus la fatigue que tu as
accumulé cette journée-là fait que ça
frappe en même temps quand la caféine
s'en va fait que là j'écoute ce samedi
dimanche fais rien le lundi je le fais
le protocole je me réveille
je bois un verre d'eau je travaille un
peu devant ma lampe qui simule le soleil
parce que cette journée là il y avait
pas de soleil supérieur je fais du
travail je réponds à des emails
une heure et demie deux heures après mon
réveil je prends mon premier café
quand je suis arrivé en après-midi vers
deux heures où est-ce que d'habitude ça
crachait je me suis dit puis là je te
mens pas je me suis dit si c'est ça si
ça c'est comment je me sentir pour le
reste du genre de ma vie c'est un cheat
codes je venais de réaliser que c'était
pas que je commence je me sentais avant
c'était pas normal c'était pas un effet
normal il faut que je me dis bon mais
c'est sûrement placebo je peux pas
croire après ça toute cette la première
semaine j'avais l'impression que
j'arrivais en après-midi là j'avais
aucun crash d'après-midi je restais
super productif à 5h même j'avais encore
l'impression d'avoir pas peur RedBull
j'étais crainte j'avais encore de
l'énergie à plus savoir quoi en faire
puis j'arrivais à la fin de ma journée
fatigué de ma journée aucun problème à
m'endormir puis je continue là ça fait
un mois que je fais ça même c'est pareil
ça c'est pas parti c'est amateur je me
suis levé j'ai fait 45 minutes de jog
c'est plein de d'Abraham plein soleil je
suis revenu chez nous j'ai pris mon café
en ce moment il y a 4 heures et 20 j'ai
travaillé à matin et j'ai fait de la
drive jusqu'ici je suis encore bien j'ai
aucun down j'ai pas envie de genre
d'habitude quand je faisais ce genre
d'affaires là mettons je le sais parce
que je conduisais de Québec je me fais
un podcast pour la fin du podcast
j'étais brûlé j'étais on dirait même que
je suis crainte qui règne encore c'est
fou
c'est drôle tu dis ça mais parce que
j'ai un peu adapté la même routine genre
exactement la même mais en fait la seule
différence c'est que en fait moi
je je je strugle à trouver maintenant le
meilleur moment pour m'entraîner dans la
journée puis là c'est comme mettons dans
le jour en milieu de journée
ça s'est coupé ma journée en deux
j'aimais pas ça après ça le soir souvent
le soir c'est comme un bon moment parce
que lui je fais de ma journée et puis
je trouve que admettons s'entraîner le
soir tout comme ton stress accumulé de
la journée
sauf que
c'est tout le temps par travailler plus
longtemps arrivera pas
puis même chose je remarque que quand je
fais ça après ça je suis good je suis
good puis là ça faisait que souvent je
me faisais un café rendu ici mettons à
comme disent aux heures plus de 2h après
mon réveil même des fois je le prenais
sachant qu'il y a des fois l'après-midi
j'ai un down je disais je prenais un
café puis le prenez plus en après-midi
mettons puis même chose que toi je suis
comme maintenant j'ai plus envie de
faire le CS je suis plus là en ce moment
aussi je fous le réveiller je fous le
focus enfin que
ça change d'aller s'entraîner moi c'est
sûr de direct en me levant ça a été
vraiment gamechanger puis c'est comme
vraiment facile de mettre dans ma
routine parce que ça mange pas toute ma
journée c'est comme je me lève je vois
bon puis après ça je goûte gauche mon
café plus tard puis le Jura de la
journée je suis bien comme tu dis le
soir après ça
une mini parenthèse avant qu'on commence
à répondre aux questions mais ça c'est
mon conseil genre
mais lui ce qu'il dit c'est que le café
a une durée
life ça veut dire que le café de genre
une à quatre heures il marche à plein
potentiel après c'est de 4 à 8 diminue
de moitié des faits puis de 8 à 12
minutes quart d'effet puisqu'il dit
c'est que même si tu es capable de
t'endormir mais tant que tu prends un
café à 2h PM même si tu es capable de
t'endormir à 10h il y a encore le corps
de la caféine qui fait effet puis de ce
même si tu dors ça va nuire à ton
deepsler qui arrive dans les premières
heures de ta nuit tout le temps dans le
fond c'est la récupération plus
que je le prenais à une heure
la qualité de tes premières heures de
sommeil fait que moi je prends un peu de
café l'après-midi maintenant je prends
un café maintenant c'est vraiment deux
heures après mon réveil puis après ça je
te demande
jusqu'à fin
c'est fou à la maison puis écrivez un
commentaire ça parce que j'en ai parlé
je dirais genre que je viens de tomber
même sur la fontaine de jouvence parce
que moi j'étais là-bas c'est la vie
maintenant c'est pas ça la vie j'en
reviens pas puis j'en ai parlé à plein
de monde puis le monde m'écrive je viens
de l'essayer et puis genre
un changement comme ça
une question philosophique si parce que
aussi je pense que
est-ce qu'on qui demande la question
1 2 3
[Rires]
profiter du moment présent ou économie
pour retraite ça c'est un sujet de notre
génération je pense vraiment où est-ce
que on se retrouve un peu à la croisée
des chemins
dans on en a parlé d'économies puis de
gestion de notre argent par le passé
puis à quel point moi je mentionnais que
ça me crée un peu d'anxiété de penser à
tout ça
mais en même temps faut comme y penser
où est-ce que tu as changé
mais là mettons aujourd'hui je me situe
vraiment plus du côté
économie pour retraite que profiter de
ma présence
la retraite
parce que c'est en ce moment mon travail
je le considère c'est un travail mais
dans le sens que je me vois pas arrêter
de faire ça mais ton frère de la musique
ou faire des ou faire des podcasts
je peux continuer je vais continuer à le
faire je peux comme à 65 ans je veux
absolument avoir fini de faire ça fait
qu'on verra je continue aussi longtemps
que je vais envie de le faire mais
toutes les discussions qu'on a eu à
propos d'épargne boutique quand tu
écoutes tu montes comme maxwin ou
n'importe qui ils vont tout te dire
l'argent économise aujourd'hui
dans de Line vaut exponentiellement plus
qu'est-ce que vous aujourd'hui ça c'est
sûr je me dis un petit sacrifice
aujourd'hui et qui vaut un gros gain
demain versus mettons quelque chose que
je me gode aujourd'hui
ben c'est quelque chose que je pourrais
je pourrais pas me gâter 10 fois plus
tard que moi je me dis aussi bien
aujourd'hui faire un sacrifice pour
pouvoir vraiment profiter plus tard
surtout que moi justement j'ai une job
qui est personne n'y est pas j'ai pas un
fond de retraite qui se fait
automatiquement ou de pensions ou quoi
que ce soit c'est l'argent vraiment que
je mets de côté c'est ça que je vais
avoir un bout de ligne
sauf que justement le fait mais j'ai
commencé quand même
jeune sachant que je dis que je fais une
carrière en musique
possiblement je ferais pas
500 000 par année
10 % 15 % de côté c'était pas aussi
clair que ça mais j'ai tout le temps à
chaque année si ma rester mettons je le
mettais dans un compte réel c'est lié au
lever effectivement en 10 ans de faire
ça je suis quand même un petit
un petit moton mais que lui
plus tu en as et puis tu le gardes
longtemps ça c'est exponentiel
finalement
je suis vraiment plus de je fais quand
même attention mais dépenses puis
j'essaie d'être raisonnable je sais pas
de
trucs que j'ai pas nécessairement besoin
juste pour me gâter ou c'est je veux
aller au resto puis ça va me coûter 100
pièces
je suis pas genre moine mais
mais ouais j'essaie d'en mettre le plus
possible de côté je me dis je vais
pouvoir en profiter 10 fois 20 fois plus
tard que comme l'autre puis on verra
plus tard qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
que je comprends t'es pas je pense pas
que je suis là parce que
premièrement dans ce que tu dis mettons
je comprends que
l'argent que tu mets de côté maintenant
va valoir beaucoup plus tard mais les
expériences que tu vis maintenant vont
aussi être positionné à valoir plus cher
que ce que tu peux faire plus tard mais
vont être vécues d'une façon que tu peux
plus vivre plus tard fait que mettons
l'idée justement de
d'aller prendre cet exemple puis loin de
moi l'idée de dire que je fais ce genre
d'affaires là parce que ça c'est pas moi
puis je pense pas que j'aurais du fun à
la hauteur de ce que ça coûterait mais
attends mais genre aller au resto puis
je sais pas que ça coûte 400 pièces
parce que
c'est une affaire là tu te couches à
trois heures parce que pilote est comme
c'est une expérience que tu vis mettons
que tu peux plus revivre après quand tu
es rendu à 70 ans maintenant on le dit à
60 ans ou est-ce que là tu peux pas
vraiment ravoir ce genre de plaisir là
faire des trucs que tu fais dans 30 ans
que tu peux pas vraiment faire dans ce
fontaine tu sais mais ton vive un voyage
j'ai pas mal en Espagne puis faire des
affaires que tu peux pas faire quand on
s'entendais puis avoir l'énergie vitale
que tu as maintenant que tu auras pas
nécessairement plus tard
je pense que tu peux voyager en Espagne
aussi à 60 ans c'est juste pas le même
genre de voyage je comprends de pas la
même expérience puis tu l'as pas
maintenant
tu l'auras plus
tu comprends c'est du temps qui passe
que tu aurais pu cette expérience là de
cette façon là puis si ta vie pas
maintenant ta vie juste pas j'ai
l'impression il y a l'aspect non mais je
veux juste j'ai quand même le sentiment
que que je vis des expériences
le fait le fait de faire la musique
j'ai voyagé quatre fois en deux dangers
je vis des affaires quand même
c'est juste que tu mettes tu peux ou tu
mettons justement aller au resto que ma
blonde puis partager un moment genre
vraiment une tente qualité puis parler
puis je vais rester longtemps
moyen de le faire sans que ça coûte
je mets ça dans des dépenses qui en
valent la peine versus mettons
non mais c'est ça je suis pas en train
de dire quand on dit profiter de
l'instant présent c'est pas de dépense
qui vaut pas la peine c'est juste des
dépenses qui vendent la peine de faire
juste des dépenses qui veulent la peine
parce que sinon il y a la question se
pose pas vraiment tu sais mais il y a
aussi c'est ça en fait moi je dirais les
deux métiers je voudrais essayer de
profiter du moment présent mais en étant
quand même genre consciencieux genre de
comment se dépenses pour pouvoir
profiter ta retraite aussi mais ça c'est
sûr c'est une réponse un peu un peu
facile
obligé de dépenser tant que ça pour
veiller des expériences qui vont marquer
[Musique]
des affaires que je veux dire
je sais pas
des gens un charneuf aussi que c'est
comme c'est pas que c'est ce qui va
t'amener plus de bonheurs dans ta vie
aussi mettons tu sors dans un bar ça te
coûte 200 pièces
et le 200 pièces
mon exemple c'était pas nécessairement
le meilleur exemple parce que je ferais
pas ça je veux jamais c'est pas quelque
chose qui en vaut la peine pour moi mais
non mais c'était plus dans l'idée de
dire que certaines expériences que de
vivre à 30 ans versus tu sais des
expériences sur pas nécessairement que
il faut que tu sortes de ta
faut que tu sors de ta zone pour les
vivre
mais
toi tu aimes ça allait à ce ton âme
courir d'un trail ça te coûte 0 de
pièces ouais je sais mais j'adorerais
vraiment mais ton genre allez faire le
tour du Mont Blanc maintenant ça me
coûterait vraiment cher d'aller faire ça
genre tu comprends puis là je me retiens
un peu de le faire je me dis je peux pas
vraiment le faire puis mais je peux plus
le faire quand j'ai 60 ans mais aussi je
le fais ce sera pas la même façon de le
faire tu comprends
l'autre question à ça c'est comme puis
moi je rentre pas trop là-dedans parce
que tu penses de même tu vis juste pas
là mais de dire et je peux mourir demain
mais
je pense que du moment si maintenant on
a parlé avec les podcasts sur les
finances personnelles
pour ma retraite j'aimerais ça avoir
économisé tant
ta mère un peu de côté au fur et à
mesure moi je te dis que ce qui reste
toutes les expériences
sur l'établisse comme ça c'est à quel
point est-ce que tu veux mettre de côté
puis une fois que tu as mis cette ligne
là une fois que ça c'est fait c'est
réglé c'est automatique
[Musique]
trouver la juste
pierre ok
nos questions Marie Gervais quel est
votre langage de l'amour
qui on va se sortir pour pas l'oublier
je pense que
si genre confirmation
le mettre au dessus de tout genre tu es
dans le sens
je peux vous donner un exemple de ma vie
récemment mais toi ma blonde à travers
vraiment beaucoup et puis à l'honneur
complètement débile c'est puis amener
j'écoute la télé et à Québec pendant
pendant un mois puis a fini de
travailler puis d'étudier pas possible
qui finit genre à 8 puis là
je vois genre
aider aux tâches ménagères mettons parce
que je suis juste comme
moi j'avais fait de la cuisine à la fin
de la vaisselle c'est puis ça me
dérangeait pas parce qu'elle faisait
quelque chose pas comme si elle faisait
rien puis là
va pas comme passer la balayeuse en bas
là fais juste tenir c'est tellement plus
important pour moi que n'importe quoi tu
peux faire
comme de physique qui m'aiderait puis
elle mais ça fait ça tu penses que elle
ça serait act of service c'est ça
exactement c'est tellement pas ça genre
je comprends moi c'est pas ça pas en
tout cas mais c'est compliqué quand
c'est pas c'est pas ça même ligne mais
oui
pour ceux qui savent mettant pour ceux
qui savent pas c'est quoi là c'est une
théorie le langage de l'amour selon
laquelle il y aurait 5 on avait parlé
avec Julien Harun allait écouter ce
podcasts
qu'on aime donner l'amour qui recevra
puis on peut aimer donner une manière et
recevoir une autre doit être différent
de comment qu'on aimer recevoir ou
pareil puis quand tu caches ce
quatre réfléchit là dessus parce que ça
peut vraiment aider à
reconnaître
si mettons je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de situations de couple mettons que les
deux se comprennent pas parce qu'ils ont
pas la même façon de démontrer à l'autre
qui s'aiment puis ça peut permettre de
s'en rendre compte parce que si toi et
les cadeaux tu n'as rien à cirer puis
que l'autre t'amène tout le temps des
petites pensées que j'ai acheté ça tout
était comme je m'en fous je m'en fous
une fois que tu casques ok cette
personne là sa manière de montrer quand
même
[Musique]
ben même si tu t'en fous ben tu peux au
moins apprécier le fait que
démonstration sur
leur partenaires l'école Paul il se
sentent pas qu'ils sont pas que les
personnes les aime mais jusqu'au
personne tellement peu la même façon
bref
moi c'est
je dirais
probablement physique en premier
qui commence
[Musique]
je veux dire à ma blonde que chacun est
belle 14 fois par demi
puis genre mettons si on s'est fait si
on sait pas d'école le matin puis le
soir c'est comme il y a un manque là il
y a quelque chose
mettons si on passe une coupe de jour
sans vrai dire sans avoir sa proximité
là
il va
en dernier que je n'ai rien à chier
c'est les cadeaux c'est ma blonde
à Noël
c'est important de savoir ça c'est
important
puis quoi Lily time pour elle c'est pas
mettons écouter un film tu sais si genre
concentré genre les dans le blanc des
yeux et puis genre mettons aller au
resto puis avoir une bonne conversation
juste comme ça sur le divan puis parler
mais genre si on est juste collé au
moins avoir ses écoles touch mais
mettons qu'on écoute de quoi pour elle
ça compte pas
ta maison mettons que j'arrive
petit je le sais que mettons on a pas
beaucoup de temps de même mais là
mettons je vais mettre en mode faut
quand même que je sois homme parce que
elle c'est important que genre la
présence d'esprit puis qu'on connecte
puis qu'on Jasse ok c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça oui
rapidement parce que je sais que je
connais la réponse là mais ton frère
ouais parce que le plan oui a terminé de
tourner son troisième long métrage
Le Perche Sword
est-ce que tu as impliqué dans le
troisième ben est-ce que vous êtes un
prix en troisième long-métrage de Pascal
plante acteur figurant composteur parce
que faut savoir que moi j'avais un rôle
clé dans son deuxième important dans son
deuxième film Nadia berryfly qui a été
pris pour la sélection officielle de
Cannes
sans dire totalement grâce à un
performance
mais bref suite à cette performance
extraordinaire moi j'ai aucun lien dans
son troisième film j'ai même c'est la
première fois que parce qu'elle fait
quelque chose que je lis pas le scénario
avant qu'il fasse tout de suite
de commentateurs mais tout un rôle dans
ce ouais dans ce projet là ouais moi
dans le fond je compose la musique du
film
et puis je suis justement là-dedans le à
fond en ce moment parce que lui il finit
son montage là aujourd'hui on est
quelle date sommes-nous
on est le 25 au moment où 25 janvier au
moment de d'enregistrer sa podcast lui
il a fini de tourner à
9 ans il y a fait son montage plus
rapidement que n'importe qui tu connais
mon frère fucking hyperactif faites-le
m'envoyer son montage en décembre
j'ai commencé à travailler sur la
musique fin dans le jardin
puis
le schladda à fond il faut que ça soit
fini pour début mars ok c'est quand même
un bon challenge de façon genre deux
mois sais-tu premièrement tout ce que tu
fais c'est 100% original mais c'est
c'est trame sonore mais est-ce que dans
le film il y a des chansons
qui sont des chansons qui a pris les
droits d'auteur à quelque part des
petites Pascal lui fait ça il met
beaucoup de tonnes
il met des tonnes c'est maintenant dans
son dernier film
pour ce film là
ça fit à moins c'était comme plus
il voyait plus vraiment un score le
titre que d'avoir des taux de différents
artistes c'est quelque chose d'uniforme
puis ce genre d'univers créer laisse un
peu ça peut médiéval et
puis
en même temps tout un peu oui parce que
c'est un genre de film c'est qu'il parle
de tueur en série c'est un peu dark la
musique c'est dark mais c'est comme Dirk
baroque un peu
Jean Sébastien Bach me Dracula
[Musique]
Nice prochaine
ok je suis peu c'est que tu trouves que
tu es une question de joke pour pourquoi
quand je m'endors avec le cul qui pique
le lendemain j'ai les doigts qui puent
tu trouves studio
préfère un bon 20 minutes là-dessus je
suis pas votre vision des changements
climatiques il va trop longtemps que
consommateur grosse caisse
moi je pense qu'on a tout un rôle
individuel en tant que consommateur
mettons d'être informé puis faire des
bons choix dans la mesure des possibles
je pense que le rôle
je pense que les grands changements vont
toujours passer par en haut ça ça va
passer par
des législations puis des leaders qui
prennent des décisions et qui font les
changements
les statistiques mettons de l'impact
d'une personne ou même de genre une
population complète versus une usine x
une compagnie
pourquoi je prends ma parole en métal
même au McDo mais pourquoi je vais au
McDo premièrement
autrement mais c'est ça mais ça devient
cynique même quand tu vois ces affaires
là de pas les regarder et puis de de
rester conscientisé personnellement dans
tes choix et tout pour faire des choix
les plus éthiques peu importe à quel
niveau mais
quand tu vois à quel point il y en a qui
sont coalisme puis que le monde
s'encollé son impact tellement plus
démesuré que le monde qui ont ça à coeur
les consommateurs justement les
industries qui polluent un McDo ouever
il va pas il va pas c'est sûr mais
mais si des sanctions pour ses
compagnies-là aussi
ils vont modifier
le système est fait que genre faut qu'on
aille j'en travaille les gens doivent se
déplacer puis
le mettons c'est cool on fait un virage
électrique mettons les
bravo sauf que
on le sait que juste on continue de
consommer autant de chats puis autant de
plus en plus de chars parce que des
chats qui vendent tout le temps plus je
pense dans les dernières années ça ça
décuplés
c'est juste c'est qu'il y a pas de
transport transport en commun
[Musique]
si on continue toutes de se déplacer
chacun
je veux dire avec plus en plus de monde
avec plus en plus de ça marchera pas
actifs
notre podcast sur les élections
provinciales
densification des villes
puis c'est Étienne Grandmont qui est un
candidat solidaire qui je pense a été
en
été élu je pense en fait dans saint
Jean-Baptiste dans mon dans mon comté à
Québec qui a partagé sur Twitter un
espèce de photos de genre
qu'est-ce que c'est avec la genre
l'étalement urbain versus qu'est-ce que
ça pourrait être puis voyant ça mettons
là j'ai une crise de panique parce que
mettons moi Montréal je rentre dans
Montréal ça me crée de l'anxiété pour
plusieurs raisons mais une de ces
raisons là c'est que je trouve ça
tellement impersonnel gentil mais ton
les c'est juste on regarde par la
fenêtre en ce moment là faudrait que tu
me payes vraiment cher pour habiter dans
un de ces blocs d'avoir quelqu'un en
haut de moi
tu vas entendre le gars se lever le
matin tu vas entendre la rue rouler
dehors tu vas entendre à moins que tu
ailles un asticot d'eau à 350 000 en
montant avec des murs de béton puis
genre bonne chance le thé puis
de vivre dans ça moi-même je vois ça
puis j'ai envie de me coller ça
peut-être dans un mur là puis après ça
puis je comprends que dans cette
utopie slash dystopie selon quitter là
tout le monde prend le tramway tout le
monde est électrique prend le vélo pour
aller au travail tout le monde
mais moi-même je vois ça puis ça
m'angoisse au plus haut point là puis
l'idée de pas pouvoir mettons avoir un
char puis m'en aller dans le bois est
une idée qui me terrifie
fait que moi je vis un peu avec cette
espèce de dichotomie là à l'intérieur
même de moi-même ou est-ce que je sais
que la façon de faire les affaires pour
que mettons si on veut maximiser l'être
humain c'est de faire ça mais avant de
piler sur ma liberté personnelle je veux
sonner comme c'est Radio X mais avant de
piler sur ma liberté personnelle
par souci de protéger l'environnement
alors que l'environnement que les
humains habitent sa planète c'est
surtout au Canada c'est minime versus si
on veut parler du de l'espacement que ça
prend pour élever toutes les animaux
qu'on consomme anyway c'est un autre
dossier mais quand je vois ce que la
queune idée politique veut me mettre la
responsabilité à moi de devoir
me densifier en ville je trouve ça fou
de devoir ça puis ça ça me terrorise de
penser que ça c'est une des avenues
qu'on veut explorer pour réduire
le transport alors que des
multinationales qui brûlent du gaz juste
pour brûler du gaz tu sais si je trouve
ça débile de penser que moi faut que je
donne mon char parce que il faut que tu
donnes ton char c'est juste que mettons
tu peux décider de pas être en ville
c'est juste que de plus en plus le monde
décide de pas être en ville mais de se
déplacer en ville tout le temps je veux
dire si il y a plein tu peux tu peux
être en ville
les week-ends
[Musique]
tu prends l'ascenseur pour aller jusqu'à
ton jusqu'à chez vous même
45 étages
c'est encore plus angoissant
possible
la ville comme métier comme d'habitude
comme Blade Runner mais comme du béton
puis j'ai assez gris puis c'est
dégueu il y a pas de verdure ça c'est
sûr mais si tu prends des humains puis
j'étais étudié à aller au Festival d'été
là plus tu densifies les humains plus
qu'un tas de marde j'en ai ça c'est
comme c'est vrai le plus tu vas dans des
places dance plus les êtres humains
agissent comme du bétail et puis plus ça
devient débile plus tu mets des gens à
proximité plus le monde devienne fou
mais ça c'est des affaires d'urbanisme
je veux dire je voudrais c'est sûr que
manière d'optimiser ça pour le bien-être
du monde mais je suis d'accord avec toi
je veux dire
la fin de semaine de ma fête le jour je
veux pas déprimer personne la fin de
semaine de ma semaine de ma fête à 15
janvier ma fête ok ça vient de passer la
semaine de ma fête
il a fait de zéro
rappelle pas d'une semaine un 15 janvier
qui fait zéro depuis que la neige fonde
c'est angoissant un niveau élevé c'était
quand même Chris il me semble mais
canicule arrête pas là au moins l'hiver
arrive l'hiver il fait 0 on est quand
même on est bien on a un hiver doux
ça janvier c'est pas c'est débile on est
au Québec bon présage non c'est fou
maintenant
les cibles de s'il y en a eu il y en a
eu puis une puis un autre décide de
genre qu'il faut pas que on émette plus
que si faut pas que ça soit plus facile
ok ça va dépasser mais qui lance cible
puis là
celle-là
en plus c'est genre comme la dernière
fois j'entendais Dubois parler de ça
c'est comme c'est pas de savoir s'il va
avoir des changements climatiques c'est
qu'il faut s'arranger pour vivre avec
moi
thématique c'est pas c'est pas dans le
futur c'est pas il va avoir des
changements climatiques il y a des
sécheresses partout il y a des villes
que l'Afrique du Sud qui ont pu domaines
puis il faut qu'il y ait genre chercher
un iceberg pour avoir de l'eau fraîche
même quand ils font du vent en chercher
un autre même puis genre c'est des feux
de forêt même c'est des populations
qu'il faut qu'ils se déplacent parce
qu'il y a des des des ouragans c'est
c'est avoir entraîner même dans les
prochaines décennies crissement des
changements au niveau
géopolitique les gens des populations
complètes il faut falloir qu'il soit
relocaliser puis on sait que ça fait le
calcul du monde qui viennent sur le ou
deux personnes arrivent si je rentre son
genre vraiment bienvenu ça va faire
crissement des conflits ça va être un
une place qu'on est quand même bain qui
fait pas trop chaud
pour les réfugiés les réfugiés
climatiques ça puis genre éthiquement on
n'aurait pas mal le choix qui était je
veux dire donner juste chanceux d'être
ici puis d'avoir des effets pas trop
pires genre on n'est pas on manque pas
d'eau puis c'est pas la sécheresse c'est
pas genre mais mais ça va être ça va
être intéressant même je pour m'endormir
le soir quand ma tête se met à spinner
puis penser à ça on dirait que je me
genre je me dis
qu'il faut faire comme confiance à
l'innovation humaine
parce que si on fait juste partie si on
continue dans cette trajectoire là on
est d'aide puis on
reviendra pas à une vie plus simple dans
le sens que la technologie est elle
existe puis on le découvert puis genre
le genre de retour c'est sûr à la terre
la règle la décroissance ça se passe pas
ça va être ça va être mais ton jean
le salut va venir parler l'innovation
exactement
je me dis c'est la seule espoir que j'ai
c'est de faire on était en ligne de
notre barre et amenez quelqu'un va
trouver une technique même de genre
refroidissement planétaire qu'on va être
capable de mettre genre parce que sinon
tu t'endors pas tu es dans un sens la
science nous a amené où est-ce qu'on est
une personne un effort humanitaire on a
trouvé comme des bêtises à tous les
jours il y a des nouvelles affaires et
puis qui réfléchissent à ça et puis
c'est sur toutes les aspects le séance
la couche d'ozone
que il y avait un trou on le dit là on
embarde un trou il faut arrêter de faire
si ce faut arrêter le surplus à caca on
l'a arrêté trousse referme ok quand même
de l'espoir dans le sens que peut-être
que la planète peut se réguler plus
quand même si on change les affaires
venir un peu à l'arrière
on le voit le timeton
les projections
apparemment quand même pas mal puis la
plupart des scientifiques disent nourris
que ça va arrêter à deux ça va continuer
puis genre à trois quatre et plus le ça
commence à être genre l'Apocalypse le
pas loin d'être seul
ça va être intéressant de
du vin Rousseau du vent Rousseau
l'amitié le parcours en adolescent
adulte qu'est-ce qui veut qu'est-ce qui
veut dire qu'est-ce qui veut savoir mais
en fait
la différence que où est-ce qu'on va
l'amener cette question qui est vraiment
une question c'est quoi la différence
entre notre relation amitié en nous
mettons là de adolescent à adulte
qu'est-ce qui a changé maintenant là on
se voit vraiment moins souvent qu'on se
voyait à l'adolescence parce que
l'adolescence on se voyait littéralement
tous les jours mais quand on se voit
c'est pas vraiment différent
je pense que dans ce temps-là on n'était
plus
on avait tout en commun un sens qu'on
avait la même vie le même cercle d'amis
le même horaire même école même sport
même hobby même toute factice on était
vraiment quasiment la même personne
même si en plus on a comme des contextes
familial
vraiment et ça ressemble folle
pilote et je pense que en tant qu'adulte
on se trouve le type et puis genre
on devient chacun des personnes nos
propres personnes j'ai pas comment dire
le type et avec nos champs
on partage toujours ce même comme tronc
commun
on vient la même place
de travail qui rentre là-dedans qui vont
en général bien une question justement
par rapport à ça c'est que si on se
séche que je tenait ah ouais
par rapport à la job dans le fond ça
fait quand même longtemps que ça arrive
par rapport à la job
ensemble un lien avec la business
je me rappelle pas qu'on a eu car nous
un gros désaccord non vraiment
mais moi je me souviens où tout début il
y a eu un désaccord ça c'est sûr quand
même fondamental
de est-ce qu'on fait le podcast sur une
chaîne Youtube que propre à elle où on
le met sur ta chaîne Youtube que tu
avais dans le temps
ah ouais on a eu non
parce que tout avait été quand même tu
avais déjà un bon following sur la
chaîne Youtube que tu avais dans le
temps
de couple puis de véganisme
je pense qu'on devrait avoir notre
propre chaîne Youtube c'était comme on a
déjà des followers ça va nous aider
on en parle puis souvent on réfléchit à
ça et on en arrive en même conclusion
genre même si même si on tient notre but
pendant le moment puis après ça c'est
genre on prend on dort là-dessus puis on
fait genre le lendemain celui qui il y
en a un des deux qui réalise que l'autre
plus largement que ça c'est même d'envie
en général mettons de demander mettons
que tu arrives plus tu as un opinion
différente d'essayer de convaincre une
autre personne de ton opinion puis de
s'attendre à ce que au moment où est-ce
que tu apportes des nouvelles
informations échange son opinion puis
quand c'est pas le cas être fâché mais
attends c'est con là parce que là j'ai
des nouvelles informations
donne-moi le temps d'y penser
comment tu veux que on soit en accord
maintenant tu sais j'ai eu aucune aucun
temps de réflexion puis là je dis ça
comme si
exact mais c'est ce mais justement on ne
jamais tendre désaccord parce que je
pense qu'on a un fond
comme
on veut les deux là même à faire sans
qu'on s'en parle vraiment c'est mettons
le hand Gaulle parce que c'est pas bon
le ngo ça existe pas and gold mais genre
les objectifs à court moyen long terme
souvent c'est les mêmes quand on s'en
parle on fait juste des fois redresser
un peu où est-ce qu'on est juste pour le
situer genre mais au final les deux on
est pas mal tout le temps dans le même
idée que ce soit va avoir au podcast ou
au studio toutes les autres projets dans
la même thématique il y a S Carron un
c04
ta mère qui dit dans la mathématique
l'importance des longues amitiées trois
points d'exclamation
on en parlait dans un autre contexte en
pissant mais oui mais moi c'est
maintenant
sachant ce que je sais le 32 ans j'ai
vécu un peu
puis sachant que je sais même un des
plus gros red flags que je vais avoir
pour le reste de ma vie c'est quand tu
arrives dans la vie de quelqu'un qui a
pas de longues amitiés ok pas capable de
tenir des longues amitiés c'est tout du
monde que du Nouveau Monde dans son
cercle c'est ce c'est quand même un bon
réflexe ça ça montre que c'est souvent
du monde qui s'allienne les gens autour
d'eux ça dure un temps
si finalement il y a quelque chose qui
se passe qui fait que la personne la
dose
personne des nouvelles personnes c'est
ton nouveau meilleur ami
incroyable ça dure deux mois après ça
cette personne-là disparaît complètement
de sa vie c'est fou si quelqu'un qui va
encore ses amis de secondaire puis
encore des longues amitié de même c'est
quand même signe que
c'est ta personne là peut-être pas
backstable de première heure
à mettre en feu toutes les relations
capacité enfin que effectivement
cultiver l'amitié parce que tu mettes je
veux dire j'ai des exemples en tête de
genre ah non j'ai encore aimé que mon
monde secondaire mais si je raquette
déjà vu une fois dans le dernier 3 ans
genre que vous avez un groupe chat
une amitié
mais moi même rendu le ça c'est rendu un
des plus gros flags
[Rires]
Béatrice Kurt dans la même thématique
parlez-nous d'anecdotes d'enfance je
sais pas tout à l'heure je pensais que
tu voulais que je pensais que c'est
l'autre question
je suppose pourquoi tu avais dit
sérieuse on y reviendra une anecdote
d'enfance peut-être quelque chose qui
devient là
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai repensé à ça
l'autre fois
c'était au début d'Instagram ou est-ce
que il y a pas beaucoup de monde qui
voulait être historique ou du moins si
on n'était pas suivi par beaucoup de
monde fait que
des amis préaudés ah vraiment vraiment
une anecdote minable mais ça me fait
rire quand j'y repenser l'autre fois
puis tu venais t'acheter des nouveaux
souliers
puis on est je rappelle on est dans
l'aquarium puis on voulait faire un gag
mais c'est la pire joke puis qu'est-ce
qu'on fait moi je t'ai monté dans
l'arbre petit gros arbre à côté de la
piscine je te montre juste descendu mes
culottes puis j'avais fait j'avais
montré mes fesses j'ai dirigé mes fesses
vers toi plutôt tu avais à côté
de Vitré genre peut-être une photo de
tout puis tu avais marqué genre
Instagram même au début des story
Instagram c'est fou quand même en même
temps Instagram c'est tellement rendu
[Musique]
ça serait plus chacun que ça mais
surtout maintenant aujourd'hui avec les
mettant le
followings bref trouver dans mes
archives mes premières c'était ma
première c'est celui que j'avais fait
ever c'était
c'est la première fois genre je n'ai
d'ouvrir Instagram
mais Instagram quand même fait un
institut de flipper parce que quand ça a
commencé c'était que de la nourriture
que des photos de bouffe puis là
maintenant activement mon agorithme
monte deux choses et puis je l'aide pas
ses affaires-là quand je les vois je
clique sur trois petits points ceci ne
m'intéresse pas mettons puis c'est les
filles qu'on s'est envoyé l'autre fois
genre que le son juste nu sur Instagram
dans le fond carrément
[Musique]
mais je pense
la ligne ou dans le sens que parce que
là
tu pouvais pas être mettons
Instagram mais
mais vous pouvez avoir un truc
transparent il laissait comme la
transparence de plus en plus
transparente permanence c'est comme
littéralement comme c'est comme ça
derrière
mettre une ligne à quelque part c'est
flou on veut juste faire bon ah ouais
ouais
c'est ça ou genre des vidéos
de genre
de santé mentale chez les hommes
moi j'ai ça mon amour mon affaire le
jardin des côtes avec une musique triste
de genre des acteurs qui pleurent parce
que mettons ils sont pas bien nos
affaires même
puis je veux dire je blague pas ça puis
je suis pas dans un mot de dépressif
puis je recherche pas des
antidépresseurs sur Google écoute des
trucs
sauf que là puis en plus j'en ai parlé
un peu de ça puis on dirait que il y a
plein de monde que c'est ça genre de
vidéo avec une musique triste de genre
quelqu'un qui qui dit genre quand tu es
tout seul mais tu continues à aller au
gym déjà
ça me regarde pas
regardez-moi c'est quoi dans mon seul
genre la musique pas mal mais j'ai
beaucoup de filles aussi
beaucoup de filles mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux ça
sinon des gens d'extrait de podcast ou
sinon des trucs en lien avec la musique
[Musique]
croyez vous qui est possible d'utiliser
les réseaux sociaux d'une façon saine
la seule raison en ce moment pour que
j'ai encore ça c'est à cause que c'est
un peu mon travail maintenant mais
personnellement
genre je suis vraiment
dépassé par ce je suis tellement tanné
on dirait je suis fatigué
de ce je suis épuisé de comme toute la
chute
sur les réseaux sociaux même depuis
au moins là on dirait que ça c'est un
peu calmé la haine puis la marde puis
l'espèce de pointage de doigt là à moins
que j'aille juste commencer à arrêter de
suivre tout le monde les deux peut-être
mais je pense que c'est moins pur mais
ça a été fou même pendant un bottes
qui était pull fun
je pense qu'on a toute collectivement un
problème de dépendance aux cellulaire
puis que on en parle même pas on en
parle même pas presque pas comme si
c'était un problème sérieux mais genre
c'est puis genre moi honnêtement j'ai
quand même
quand même de la misère je suis pas le
pire
escrocs
le réflexe de comme mon téléphone est
juste là juste de le prendre de l'ouvrir
puis le faire pour que je vienne faire
ça puis le mettre ce matin c'est comme
c'est constant c'est genre je fais tout
le temps ça et puis
Facebook puis je vois quelque chose dans
facebook et un article intéressant c'est
comme on dirait que ça
c'est comme design pour parce que moi ça
me fait l'effet que genre ça me défocus
constamment parce que même chose mettons
un message
ton sans filtre sur un message sur la
page mais le pour y aller je me va sur
Instagram puis je vois autre chose puis
là je me voilà
c'est top de
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je viens de faire avec ma
vie avec mon temps pourquoi j'ai fait ça
que ça m'a donné ici effectivement
sur Facebook
c'est mettons des fois je vous disais
des pages de trucs qui m'intéresse de
temps en temps il y a vraiment des
articles comme ça ça m'intéresse jolie
là-dessus ça c'est à travers justement
plein de bruit là
on pouvait chemin filtrer ça un peu plus
puis
mais ouais c'est c'est
fait pour c'est fait pour ça c'est pour
ça c'est ça pour nous avoir
lié à ça il y avait une question
justement
qui demande que pensez-vous des métiers
qui sont en danger due à l'intelligence
artificielle mais même à faire le doute
de demain principalement pour ceux qu'on
la reçoit pour parler de
[Musique]
je pense que
on n'a pas fini de
devoir s'ajuster face à aux technologies
qui étaient remplacé par des machines
puis de fil en aiguille
[Musique]
on s'est concentré dans certains types
de jobs délégués d'autres puis je veux
dire c'est certaines types de Job là
sont pas à l'abri non plus le remplacés
éventuellement et puis
si la technologie permet
on va y aller
on va
si ça coûte moins cher faire une job par
un robot qui est par un humain c'est sûr
qu'on va y aller au moins qu'il y a des
lois mettons
la transition qui est chiante la
personne qui est perdu ça job parce que
une machine le remplacer ça le fait
chier sûrement mais genre 50 ans plus
tard
c'est que jobby existe plus mais tant
pis personne qui qui triste aujourd'hui
c'est la même chose pour
[Musique]
dans le fond des illustrations il y
avait juste du monde mais c'est ça le
point c'est moi qui faisait puis là
c'est comme ok maintenant je peux avoir
un robot qui le fait 3,99 dans le 400 et
je veux dire 400 qui sont honnêtement
mettons dans juste je vais en effet de
faire 20 et moi maintenant puis dans ces
20 là genre si je voulais avoir un
avatar je l'ai pas besoin d'en faire
faire un autre pour le match je paye une
Illustrator pour le faire il serait
probablement moins haute ou moins mon
goût puis il faudrait que je fasse des
retouches il faudrait que dans ce cas-là
si je veux faire des retours je remets
un 3 et 99 Marc il m'a ressort sans
complètement différent
un graphiste je veux dire c'est Dole en
tabarnak pour ses
métiers là mais en même temps je vois
pas comment on peut
refermer la boîte de Pandore puis ça
c'est pour les métiers artistiques mais
en ce moment en chirurgie sont en train
de amasser une banque de données massive
à travers le monde entier pour tracer
les cotes chirurgie parce que tu sais il
y a aucun corps qui est pareil aucun
cerveau qui est pareil aucun cœur qui
est pareil mais toutes les les cœurs
mettons ont des attributs semblables et
un problème que tu vois dans une artère
tu peux le retrouver dans un autre
artère c'est que là on est en train de
ramasser toute ce cette banque de
données pour qui éventuellement ce soit
des robots qui fassent les interventions
chirurgicales puis tu enlèves
complètement la possibilité d'erreur
humaine avec ça même je veux dire oui ok
il y a plein de chirurgiens qui vont
perdre leur job mais pas du jour au
lendemain premièrement depuis
premièrement avec mon retraite au moment
c'est à place de du roulement perdre
leur job ils vont juste aller à retraite
puis ça va être une transition mais
c'était pour enlever l'erreur humaine
c'est ça que tu veux même chose pour les
chats tu peux faire un grid planifier
tout le monde mettons un algorithme
gigantesque qui fait que tout se conduit
tout seul
tu enlèves l'erreur humaine de toutes
les équations semaines
[Rires]
mais oui mais oui 100%
le ou est-ce que je trouve qu'il y a
que c'est dangereux c'est juste que
on délègue le plus en plus de
notes
capacités
[Applaudissements]
pratiquement toute réflexion
un robot c'est amanique qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire en fait
qu'est-ce que le maintien va faire si on
a plus besoin de faire aucune job puis
qu'on a pu vraiment besoin de réfléchir
à rien comme dans les femmes mais c'est
super fort aucune de Manuel on devient
quoi et c'est quoi notre purple c'est
quoi genre c'est juste vivre dans le
loisiveté même vivre des petits plaisirs
de la vie même jusqu'à temps qui ont on
dirait que ça manque d'essence à ça
mais tout sur leur chaise volante des
émissions toute la journée puis ils font
rien et puis genre ils boivent leurs
petits coups les dents
artificielle pour que pour que ça fait
genre parfaitement dégoût à toi
l'expérience la plus plus optimisée
c'est débile
ça fait un peu peur
ça me ramène un peu à l'idée on parlait
plutôt dans le podcast de l'idée de
tu vas voir où est-ce que je vais en
venir là totalement
urbain puis dans ce situation rurale
elle est tellement
urbain dans une situation maintenant
des fois même retourner
fondamentalement au fond de nous puis
que je crois que c'est en danger d'être
perdu
parce que comme tu dis on est si on fait
plus rien on fait plus rien
peut-être que plus tard lui-même ça va
juste être sûr notre ville se promener
dans le bois puis genre être en famille
Jean-Pierre je vois des jeux ensemble et
puis qu'on va se dire ainsi tu débile
qu'une certaine époque on écrivait des
travailler 10 heures par jour genre on
avait une route déjà on allait à l'usine
ou analyse au bureau quand vous trouvez
ça
nous avait dit on était on est juste là
sur le fil entre
utopie dystopie puis on est en marche
cette mince ligne là
on reprend la question que pensez-vous
d'alcool on a parlé pas mal dans le
podcast la semaine passée
vas-y j'ai pas choisi j'ai pas trouvé
[Musique]
de tous les temps ok mais je veux
spinner la question différemment
il y a les nommés aux Oscars qui sont
sortis
j'ai écouté parce que moi
j'écoute pas toutes les toutes les films
des Oscars
mais je me fie quand même au top de
Pascal plantes
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé que c'était
un très très grand film mais j'ai trouvé
ça m'a déchiré le coeur c'est d'écrire
ça en morceaux
ça te dit que ça voulait faire ça a
marché j'ai l'impression que c'est étant
un jeune homme débute
ça fera particulièrement proche du coeur
cette histoire là puis
j'ai trouvé ça
pour ceux qui s'appellent c'est un film
anglais
c'est l'histoire en fait
de
souvenirs de voyage de maman ensemble
ses pieds
le film en fait pendant
presque toute la moitié je me suis dit
genre qu'est-ce que j'aimerais me
regarder c'est quoi c'est quoi ça c'est
quoi le point que le but
quand tu finis le truc
tu es chaviré alors
c'est vraiment avoir moi aussi je pense
que parce qu'elle l'avait mis premier
c'est vraiment ça va vraiment comme des
bottes
c'est en plus on dit ça comme si genre
c'était un drame à la momie mettons le
tu sais où est-ce que j'aurai des scènes
qui qui te font pleurer genre mais là
c'était pas ça c'est pas les scènes
comme tel c'est vraiment comme
l'accumulation de tout ce que tu sais
puis l'espèce d'envie crier à TV genre
de prendre la feuille
c'est fou là
mais c'est comme un taux de force c'est
comme un film comme il y en a pas le je
veux dire un schéma full bizarre
des fois ça commence au début
c'est un peu drôle des fois c'est un peu
juste comme les autres kitchell qui font
comme pourquoi je vois cette scène là de
un peu rien puis
alors c'est bouleversant
moi-même
mais jusqu'à que
tu vois à déposer pieds sur le tapis
genre
pisser le tapis qui était que qui ont vu
en voyage
à 380 pounds fait que genre un tapis qui
coûte fucking Sherman puis que là c'est
comme une thématique qui revient dans
toute le film l'argent
vous allez savoir de quoi je parle quand
vous allez arriver là parce que je
recommande dans le style tout le monde
qui écoute de checker ce fameux
sur Amazon Prime en location pour comme
15 pièces moi dans les films qui sont
devenus
j'en ai vu une coupe je n'ai vraiment
pas vu tant que ça
mais mais bon l'acteur est bon l'acteur
est bon
stop pendant deux heures et demi
mais
donc tu prends les budgets des deux
films qu'on vient de parler puis tu vois
à quel point il y en a un qui est
supérieur à l'autre en terme de qualité
cinématographique mettons
le centième du prix de l'autre à peu
près peut-être même moins que ça c'est
démesuré à quel point des fois on pense
qu'on brûle l'argent par les fenêtres on
chie dans sa pote sens
il était comme un chat l'acteur puis là
il y a comme disparu plus c'est comme un
peu ça deuxième vie deuxième chance et
puis genre il faut le touchant puis
genre tu as beau film encore une fois
car laisse-moi on veut le top moi j'ai
trouvé ça
correct mais je suis content que c'est
mais en même temps
il peut faire des acides il peut se
lever debout sur le divan puis il peut
encore continuer à faire des esthéties
mais c'est bon c'est pour ce que c'est
c'est dans le genre c'est comme ça
sinon le personnel de Jenifer
le personnage le pire personnage de
l'histoire des personnages une bonne
actrice mais c'est minable
mais c'est plus comment s'appelle
l'espèce de test ouais on a parlé avec
avec
aucun elle existe juste pour être la le
love interest de l'autre alors aucune
motivation propre à aucun pathétisme
c'est un personnage là mais bref sinon
jungle
c'est le bateau
j'ai un de plus en plus des films comme
ça même des films genre over the top un
peu
dramatique
c'est ça c'est pour les gens qui
écoutent ça fait mieux c'est grosso modo
en gros c'est une gang de riche puis
d'influenceurs en croisière sur bateau
petit
de les excès de la richesse comment je
commence mon leçon moi mettons j'ai
trouvé j'ai écouté ça j'ai trouvé ce
fucking drôle j'ai trouvé ça genre
fucking genre je trouvais que c'était
crissement maîtrisé mais ton
ça fait juste rire du monde que on
s'entend tout pour dire qu'ils sont
ridicules déjà puis qu'on fait juste
pointer du doigt ce qu'on
où est-ce que tout le monde est au
courant qu'il y a des paradis fiscaux
puis là lui sept ans après qu'il est
scandales de paradisisco arrivent avec
un film sur les paradis fiscaux tu fais
comme ah peut-être tu es plus à au goût
du jour ouais c'est ça je comprends le
point de dire
c'est facile rire des influenceurs puis
ça c'est de rire des riches maintenant
mais c'est quand même je trouve la
réalisation fucking maîtrisée je trouve
ça quand même fucking drôle des bouts de
sa porte déjà c'est un long film ça
passe vite c'est 6
moi
ma critique de ce film là c'est que
c'est un comme tu dis c'est un film
maîtrisé mais j'ai eu aucun plaisir à
l'écouter puis mettons dans j'écoute pas
assez de cinéma mais donc Pascal écoute
250 films par année j'écoute pas assez
de cinéma pour me permettre
d'avoir du fun pour vous pour me
permettre de passer deux heures plus
devant un film qui me procure aucun
plaisir à regarder c'est pas comme si en
sortant de ce film mettant en sortant de
la personne j'avais pas de plaisant
nécessairement en écoutant after Sun
mais en sortant d'after Sun j'avais
grandi
comme Pascal mentionne je savais pas ça
tu me le dis maintenant mais j'ai rien
appris là
je vais quand même ok oui je savais
genre que cette culture-là est
problématique puis j'ai acheté au
courant des inégalités sociales mettons
je savais ça fait que je viens de
regarder du monde qui chie dessus
pendant 2h30 pour rien apprendre c'est
pas ça non seulement rien à prendre
n'est pas être diverti nécessairement
parce que tu comprends moi j'étais
diverti moi j'ai trouvé ça drôle ok
j'allais pas écouter ça genre je vais
mettre des eventura si je veux rire tu
es dans le sens c'est mon but c'était
pas d'écouter ça c'est au moins tu dois
retirer quelque chose de plus grand
c'est drôle c'est quand même pas la
raison ça fait un autre c'est ça ça a
gagné
aussi tout un
peu
dans les autres films
que j'ai vu mais j'ai pas vu
les autres mais souvent c'est un cas ça
sort je me tape un marathon que j'ai pas
vu
des meilleurs films étrangers
comédie musicale au Golden Globes c'est
les benchies d'une Chirin avec Colin
Farrell c'est quand même assez
comme une comédie mais c'est un drame
comédie pour voir la comédie faut
vraiment que tu vois le deuxième niveau
c'est comme tellement over le top que
genre ça m'ennuie drôle tellement c'est
une scène mais quand même je l'ai pas vu
mais peut-être
il fait des études genre
il fait il était connu un peu comme le
genre le beau gosse un peu mais il fait
des rôles des estides films d'auteurs
il raconte que quand il est arrivé à
fait Miami Vice puis ça le Misa map à
côté à Hollywood puis il dit raconte
qu'il se rappelle pas 3 ans de sa vie il
y a trois ans de sa vie qui était comme
dans le tourbillon de genre new shot and
town le nouvel acteur irlandais qui est
débile mental plus le prix du boy place
des films complètement au budget inside
il était dans drogue par le sa taille
dans le parquet il se rappelle pas trois
ans de sa vie il est revenu chez eux en
Irlande puis le genre sa famille ça
marche pas dans la forme c'est clair ce
qui a décidé de faire c'est un film pour
manger un film pour acté faites là il se
met il s'est mis à faire plein de films
indépendants irlandais genre de lobster
c'est le même gars avec des films ultra
indépendants irlandais puis après ça il
revient pour les faits un genre Totor
recall puis là qui est un blackbuster
pour pour mettre de l'argent sa table
mais de la bouffe à table puis refait
d'autres films super Lobo jet puis
indeed c'est quand même mode c'est très
Hotmail
c'est c'est
un grand acteur
si vous avez des questions pour le
prochain fard à d'autres
questions puis c'est bon c'est parfait
ça on va les lire
comment ça commenter commenter
[Rires]